[MUSIC PLAYING]
SARA ROBINSON: My
name is Sara Robinson.
I'm a developer advocate on
the Google Cloud Platform team.
You can find me on
Twitter at srobtweets.
And I'm going to be joined
later in the presentation
by Nick Hasty,
from our customer,
GIPHY, and my teammate,
Zach Akil, another developer
advocate.
So let's get started by talking
about what is machine learning?
So at a high level,
machine learning
involves teaching computers
to recognize patterns
in the same way
that our brains do.
So as humans, it's
really easy for us
to distinguish between
a cat and a dog.
But it's much more difficult
to teach a computer
to be able to do the same thing.
But how do we actually get
from input to prediction?
This is going to depend on the
type of problem you're solving.
I like to think of
it along a spectrum.
So on the left-hand
side, let's say
you're solving a generic
task, something that someone
has already solved before.
On the opposite side
of the spectrum,
maybe you're solving
something very custom that's
specific to your data set.
Let's think of this more
specifically in terms of image
classification.
So for example, let's say
we have this image of a cat.
So the input to our model
is the pixels in the image,
and we want our model
to output the label,
that there's a
cat in this image.
So many of you know this is a
pretty common machine learning
task.
There's lots of pre-trained
models out there that exist,
that have been trained
to identify a broad range
of categories and images.
So you don't need to
start from scratch.
You can utilize
an existing model.
But let's say we
have the same image
and we want-- this
cat's name is Chloe.
And we want our model to be
able to identify Chloe apart
from the other cats
in our image library.
And maybe we even
want our model to be
able to draw a bounding box
around her in the image.
So this is going to require
us to provide our own training
data so that our model
is able to differentiate
between the different
cats in our image library.
Let's think of
this one other way
in terms of natural
language processing.
So let's take, for example,
this text from one of my tweets.
Let's say I want to extract the
parts of speech from the text.
I want my model to be
able to tell me what words
are verbs, nouns, and pronouns.
This is a pretty common natural
language processing task.
So again, I don't need
to start from scratch.
I can utilize an existing
pre-trained model
to help me with that.
But let's say I've
got the same input
and I want my model
to know that this
is a tweet about programming,
and more specifically, it's
a tweet about Google Cloud.
So for that to work,
I'm going to need
to give my model hundreds
or thousands of tweets
about each of these topics.
So that it's going to be able
to generalize and extract
those topics from new tweets
that it hasn't seen before.
So in this talk,
I want to show you
how easy it is to add machine
learning to your application
using many tools we have
available on Google Cloud
Platform.
So starting on the
left-hand side,
are products that
are targeted more
towards application developers.
We have a set of
machine-learning APIs.
So these APIs give you
access to pre-trained models.
You just need to write
one REST API request.
And you can access all
these pre-trained models
that we've already
trained for you.
You don't need to provide
any of your training data.
So it requires no machine
learning expertise to get
started.
On the other side
of the spectrum,
we have products that are
targeted more towards data
scientists and machine-learning
practitioners, people
that have a little bit
more ML experience.
So for this, we have Cloud
Machine Learning Engine,
which is our manage platform
for training and serving
your own custom
machine-learning models.
So until recently,
you'll notice there was
kind of a gap in the middle.
This is why I'm super
excited about AutoML,
which you may have heard
about in the keynote.
So AutoML is a tool that lets
you train your own custom
machine-learning models
without writing model code.
So it lets you get a little
bit more custom than you would
with the APIs, for example.
So you provide your
own training data
currently available for
images, texts, and translation.
So now that you know the
three different product areas
we're going to be
covering, let's dive right
in with machine
learning as an API.
So as I mentioned, we
have five pre-trained APIs
that give you access to
pre-trained machine-learning
models to accomplish
common ML tasks,
like analyzing images,
analyzing scenes in a video,
converting audio to
text, analyzing that text
a little further, and
then finally translating
that text into over 100
different languages.
I'm going to focus on just
two of the APIs, vision
and natural language, to
give you a taste of what
the APIs can provide.
So starting within vision,
these are all the features
of our Cloud Vision API.
So at its core, the Vision
API will answer the question,
what is this a picture of?
That's label detection.
So for this image, it might
return elephant, animal,
et cetera.
Web detection will
go a step further,
and it will look across the
web for similar, or identical,
images.
And based on the
content of those pages,
it will return tags back for
you on what's in your picture.
OCR stands for optical
character recognition.
So this can extract
text from images,
it can tell you
where that text is,
and it can even understand
the language of that text.
Skipping ahead to explicit
content detection.
This will tell you is my
image appropriate or not.
This applies to pretty
much any site that
has user-generated content.
So instead of having someone
manually screen each image,
you just make one API
call that'll tell you,
is this image
appropriate or not?
So this is what a Vision
API request looks like.
You'll notice
here, we're passing
in the URL of an image
in Google Cloud Storage.
You can also pass in
your base64 encoded image
directly in your API requests.
And then in the
features block, we just
tell the API what types of
detection we want to run.
So it's just a rest API.
You can call it in any language.
I've chosen to include
a Python example here.
So we have many client libraries
to help you access these APIs
in your favorite languages.
So here we're using the Google
Cloud Vision module for Python.
We're creating an
image annotator client.
And then we're running
label detection
and analyzing those responses.
So I never like to get too far
into a talk without a demo.
So let's go to the demo.
So to show you what's
possible with the Vision API,
this is the Vision
API product page.
And you can try out all of our
APIs directly in the browser
by uploading your own images.
So here, what I can do
is I can upload an image.
I'm going to choose
this selfie that I
took when I was seeing Hamilton
a couple of months ago.
And we can see everything we
get back from the Vision API.
So face detection
is able to tell
where my face is in the image.
It's also able to
detect emotion.
So it says, joy is very likely.
I was super excited to be seeing
Hamilton, so that is accurate.
It also identifies
where different features
are in my face.
If we skip ahead
to web detection,
based on other pictures
of the same theater,
it's able to identify
the exact theater where
I'm standing even though
the lighting in the picture
isn't great.
My favorite part
about this is what's
returned from our
text-detection end point.
So when I first
uploaded this image,
I ran it through the Vision API.
I didn't even see any
text in the image.
But you'll notice that
the word Playbill is here
on my program book,
and the API is
able to identify that for us.
And then skipping ahead here,
we can look at the full JSON
response right in the browser.
So I encourage you all to try
this out with your own images.
See if the Vision
API is right for you
before you start
writing any code.
So that's the Vision API.
We can go back to the slides
and I'll include a link
to that demo at the end.
So that was the Vision API.
Moving right along into
Cloud Natural language.
So the Natural
Language API provides
four different features.
First, it lets you extract
entities from text.
And then it lets you
detect sentiment.
So it can tell you, is this
text positive or negative.
If you want to get
a little bit more
into the linguistic
details of your text,
you can use the Analyze
syntax end point.
And then finally, the
newest feature of this
is the content classification.
So you can classify
your text into over 700
different categories.
This is an example of
calling the Natural Language
API in Node.js.
Again, it's just a REST
API, so you can use it
in any language you'd like.
So here, we're calling the
analyze sentiment end point,
and then we're analyzing
the sentiment of our text.
So let's go into a demo of
the Natural Language API.
Again, I'm going to show
the product page here.
So right in the browser
on the NLAPI product page,
I can enter text
directly in here.
So I'm going to
enter some new text.
So this is a sentence
from an article
about the World Cup published
just a couple of weeks ago.
And we will see what the
NLAPI is able to identify.
So we can see it extracts all
of these entities from our text.
So if the entity returns
a Wikipedia page,
it will link to that
page in the response.
So this is one of the players.
It links to the
Wikipedia page about him.
This links to the Wikipedia
page about the French National
football team, which is why it's
categorized as an organization
type.
And then we also
get the sentiment
for each entity, broken
down by entities.
So scores a value ranging
from negative 1 to 1,
telling us if this entity is,
overall, positive or negative.
So that's what we get
through entity analysis.
Sentiment will give us the
overall aggregate sentiment
of the entire document,
along with the sentiment
for each sentence.
From the syntax response, we
get some additional linguistic
details about the text,
which you can see here,
parts of speech, the role
of each word in a sentence.
And then finally, the content
classification end point
is able to identify that this
is an article about soccer
with 80% confidence.
It's pretty cool,
considering the words soccer,
football, World Cup, are not
actually explicitly mentioned
in the text.
And you can also look
in the documentation
to see a full list of
the content categories
that are available
from this method.
So that was the Natural
Language API demo.
We can go back to the slides.
Next, I want to highlight
one of our customers
that's using both the vision
and Natural Language APIs
in production.
And for that, I want welcome
to the stage Nick Hasty, who's
the director of R&D at GIPHY.
Welcome, Nick.
[APPLAUSE]
NICK HASTY: : Thanks, Sara.
So, hi.
My name is Nick Hasty.
I'm director of research
and development for GIPHY.
GIPHY is about a
five-year-old startup.
We have about 100 employees,
75 in New York, about 25 in LA.
So today I'm going
to talk to you
about how GIPHY used the Google
Cloud Vision APIs and Google
Cloud Natural Language
APIs to get better
metadata about our
GIFs, and to also
increase our search experience.
So the problems that we were
facing about two years ago,
we were accumulating so
many images, so many GIFs,
that the ways in which we
annotated those GIFs just
weren't cutting it anymore.
We had an editorial team.
You know, they would add
tags and labels to GIFs,
but we were working in
tens of millions of GIFs.
And we were getting
thousands more every day.
It's just not the best
use of our resources
internally to have
people slaving away
all day adding tags.
At this point in time,
there was a good amount
of availability of
machine-learning resources
for object detection in images.
We evaluated a lot
of different options,
including open source ones.
But those have
their own problems
like you've got to
deploy, and you've
got to do all these other
things, maintenance services,
and these kinds of things.
We found that the Google Cloud
API was the best thing for us
overall.
Again, what we were trying
to do is pretty simple.
We just had a bunch of images.
We just wanted to figure out
what was inside those images.
For GIPHY, knowing if
a cat is in an image
is actually a big
business deal for us.
So we wanted to pull
those things out.
In any startup, you don't
want to reinvent the wheel,
and you want to minimize risk.
So for us to not have to
train our own custom thing
and to just be able to hit
an API with an HTP request
and get like a
really good quality
metadata about an image--
huge.
It makes a job that
would, historically,
or, you know, any time,
be it like a whole team
to a single person.
So let me show you some of
the results we got for this.
So these are A/B test results.
On the left-hand side, you
can see improvements in CTR
for our search results pages
across our own, and operated.
So the bottom line,
the dark blue line,
is the control group.
And the top line, the light
blue, is our experiment group.
The experiment group, we
added Google web entities
into our search
algorithm as a signal.
Google web entities,
for us, were
really awesome, because not only
do they provide generic labels,
since they understand the
context in which a GIF is found
on the internet,
there's a lot of times
like proper names in there.
So you might find
celebrities, TV shows,
those kinds of things, which
is our bread and butter.
So yeah, when we did this A/B
test, you could see an 86--
0.86% relative
increase in CTR, which
is a really good metric for
us, and for any kind of CTR
evaluation.
And then also, the
other byproduct of this
was we were turning
less empty searches.
So on the right side,
those are non-zero results.
So we're returning,
as you can see,
we had a higher percentage of
searches that were not empty.
So a person would
search for something,
they wouldn't get anything back.
Reason being, we
had more metadata
about our GIFs, which increased
our overall relevance.
Another thing, too, is like a
lot of our long-tail searches,
we noticed those
got much better.
Because a lot of the stuff
was in kind of metadata limbo.
You know, we didn't really
have good metadata around it.
Now that we did, those things
started coming up, bubbling up,
in the algorithm.
So as we scrolled down our
pages in our search results,
we were just seeing
better stuff all around.
These numbers may
seem kind of small
in terms of, like, under 1%.
But GIPHY serves about
5 billion GIFs a day
to 300 daily, active users.
So any increase in this
amount is substantial.
OK, here's another thing we did.
Hopefully, you can see this.
We needed to come up with
better ways to title our GIFs.
We use the titles
anytime we display
GIFs on the website,
on our mobile apps,
and these other things.
So the old way we did this
before we used Google Natural
Language processing
API was we would just
get the most popular tag on
a GIF, and then we would say,
most popular tag, GIF.
Not always wrong,
but not really good.
So as you can see
in the upper left,
there's a chipmunk on the
bed, that was just bed GIF;
elephant jumping a rope,
that was just an animal GIF.
And a guy professing his
love to a woman at the door
was just a love GIF.
So what we wanted to do to
increase these titles was we
came up with a bunch
of semantic structures
like noun, verb,
adjective, noun, verb,
that we knew that would
be the best titles for us.
Then we took all our tags--
or a subset of our tags rather.
We sent them to the Google
Natural Language processing
APIs.
We figured out their
parts of speech.
The other cool thing is
the Google Natural Language
APIs returned
Wikipedia articles,
and they returned
Knowledge Graph references.
So we were able to
cross-reference those resources
to figure out when
we had a tag that
was like a proper noun
or those kinds of things.
So then we got that data and we
applied it to the structures.
We started producing
titles for these images.
You can see bottom left,
yawn-stretch GIF, elephant jump
rope GIF, Valentine's
Day hello GIF.
Way better.
We were super stoked
with all that.
That's it for us.
Real quick, again, thanks.
My name is Nick Hasty.
You can get me Nick@GIPHY.com.
And below that is a bit URL
that leads to a blog post
article on the Google
Cloud Machine Learning
blog where I go into more
detail about all this.
Thank you.
SARA ROBINSON: Thanks, Nick.
Awesome to see about customers
using these APIs in production.
So a lot of times when
I present on our APIs,
the first question
I always get is:
What if I want to train these
APIs on my own custom data?
And for that, I'm super
excited about our newest
product in cloud machine
learning, Cloud AutoML, which
lets you train your own
custom machine-learning models
for vision, natural
language, and translation
without requiring you to
write any of the model code.
So this is a diagram
of how it works.
You upload your training data,
could be images for AutoML
vision, documents, text,
sentences for AutoML Natural
Language, and then
sentence translation pairs
for using AutoML Translate.
AutoML provides a UI for
uploading your training data,
making sure your data
is labeled correctly.
You just click a
button to train it.
And then you get access
to a custom REST API
to make predictions
on that data.
And AutoML will handle
scaling it for you.
So if your model
becomes a smash hit,
you get hundreds of thousands of
requests, AutoML will scale up,
and then it will also scale
all the way back down to zero,
so you only pay
for what you use.
So let's get started
right with AutoML Vision.
To show you AutoML Vision,
we're going to dive right
into a demo.
And for this demo, let's pretend
that I am a meteorologist,
and I want to predict
weather trends and flight
plans from images of clouds.
So this begs the
question, can we
use the cloud to analyze clouds?
[LAUGHTER]
The answer is yes.
So as I was prepping
this demo, I
learned that there's many
different types of clouds,
and they all indicate
different weather patterns.
So my first thought
was, let's try this out
with the Vision API.
So for us, it's easy to see
that these are, obviously,
two different types of clouds.
But for the Vision
API, it was trained
on a broad range of different
categories of images.
We wouldn't really expect it
to know the scientific names
for these types of clouds.
You can see that
for both of them
it returns pretty much the same
label: sky, clouds, blue, et
cetera.
So the answer was build a
custom model in AutoML Vision.
And let's jump over to the
demo to take a look at that.
So this is the AutoML Vision UI.
It takes me through every
step of building and training
my model.
So here, what we have
is the Images tab.
It shows me all the images that
I'm using to train my model.
I can either create a CSV
with the URLs of my images
in Google Cloud Storage.
And in the second
column, I would
have the associated label.
Or I can upload my images
directly in the UI right here.
So you can see in
this model, our model
is going to recognize five
different types of clouds
as we see here.
And this is the number of
photos that I have for each one.
So once I've got all my
data in AutoML Vision,
the next step is to jump
over here to the Train tab.
So this is where I
can train my model.
I can look at some metrics.
So when I click
train, I can choose
how long I want to train
it for, right there.
And once my model's done
training, I'll get an email,
and then it's time to
look at some metrics
to see how my model performed.
And what I want to highlight
here is the Confusion matrix.
So it's called a
Confusion matrix.
It's actually not
that confusing.
What we want to see here
is a strong diagonal
from the top left.
So this tells us the
percentage of images
in our test set that our model
was able to classify correctly.
So when we uploaded all of
our images to AutoML Vision,
it automatically split
our images for us
into training and testing.
So when we're building any
sort of machine-learning model,
we want to take the
majority of our data
and use it to train the model.
But then when we test the
model to see how it performed,
we want to use data that
it's never seen before.
So this is evaluating
on the test data.
So we can see that it
identified 92% of my cumulus
clouds correctly.
Did pretty good for most
of them, but for this one,
it looked like there
was some issues.
So for altostratus, it only
got 58% of those correct.
Turns out it mislabelled a
lot of them as cirrus clouds.
And I can click here to see
where my model got confused.
So these were images
it predicted correctly.
These are images
that were confusing.
So this is where I can see
maybe these images were labeled
incorrectly, maybe they're
confusing images that I should
just delete from my data set.
This UI helps you go in
and see where you need
to improve your training data.
So that's the Evaluate tab.
And the most fun
part of this process
is generating predictions once
you've got a trained model.
There's a couple
of ways to do this.
I'm going to show you
how to do it in the UI.
So for this, we're
going to upload images
of two different
types of clouds,
and we're going to see
what our model predicts.
And there we go.
So this is a cumulonimbus cloud.
It's 96% confident that it
predicted that one correctly.
This is a mean type of cloud.
You probably wouldn't want to
see it if you were on a plane.
This one is a cirrus cloud.
It got 96% confidence.
So you can try out your
predictions in the UI.
It's a great way to see
how our model works right
after it's been trained.
But chances are,
you probably want
to build an application that's
going to make prediction
requests to your trained model.
So you get access to
this custom API endpoint.
Only you have access
to this, or anyone
that you share
your project with.
And let's say I decide to add
a bunch more images to improve
the accuracy of my model.
I train a new version.
All I need to do, or
all the application
developer needs to do
is change this model ID
in the API request.
So that is AutoML Vision.
We can go back to the slides.
So we announced AutoML
Vision earlier this year.
And some companies
that have been
participating in the alpha--
first is Disney.
Disney built a model to
identify specific Disney
characters, product
categories, and colors
that were specific to them.
And they use that to improve
the accuracy of their search
results.
Urban Outfitters is
a clothing company.
They built a similar model
to identify characteristics
in clothing, so types
of patterns in clothing,
types of neckline
styles, things like that.
They're using it to
automatically tag
products and improve
their recommendations
in search results.
So those are some examples
of companies using
AutoML Vision in production.
But Vision is just one
domain of machine learning.
So what about other
types of data, like text?
That's where AutoML Natural
Language comes into play.
So I wanted to start out
by talking about a couple
of potential use cases of
AutoML Natural Language--
why you might want a
custom text classifier.
So these are just a couple of
examples that I thought of.
The first was, let's say you've
got some data like a Stack
Overflow question and
you want your model
to automatically tag that
question with an associated
programming language.
Or maybe you want to
build a model that
takes a news headline,
is able to predict
where that headline came from.
I actually built a model to do
this on AutoML Natural Language
and the results were
pretty impressive.
One other example is, let's
say that you want to--
you've got doctor's
notes about a patient,
and maybe you want to predict
the possible conditions that
would be associated
with those symptoms.
To show you how this
works, I'm going
to use a demo that you may
have seen in the keynote
with a data set
from Donors Choose.
So I found this
data set on Kaggle.
Kaggle is a data science
platform that's part of Google.
If you haven't heard
of it, I definitely
recommend checking it out.
They've got a lot of
great data sets on there.
So this data set includes
data from Donors Choose.
And what they do is they
match teachers with donors.
So teachers that are looking for
resources for their classroom
will create need requests.
They have volunteers manually
categorizing those requests.
And then they use
those categories
to route their requests
to relevant donors who
are interested in
donating to the project.
So they posted this
data set to Kaggle
to see if the community
of data scientists
and machine-learning experts
could build them an automated
solution.
So I thought I would try it out
with AutoML Natural Language.
So let's go to the demo.
So as you'll see, the UI
for AutoML Natural Language
looks very similar to
the UI for AutoML Vision.
So here we have all
of the text inputs
to our model and their
associated categories.
And these are all the possible
categories in our data set.
So we can see all
the categories here.
And the Train tab looks
the same as AutoML Vision.
And we can take a look
at the Confusion matrix
to evaluate the accuracy
of how our model performed.
We can see it did pretty well.
We got, again, a strong
diagonal down the top
left, indicating
that it categorized
most of the text items from
our test set correctly.
So what we want to do
next is run a prediction
on some new text that
hasn't been categorized yet.
So we'll head over here
to the Predict tab.
And I'm going to take the
following need request.
Let me zoom in so
you can see that.
It says, my students
need aquarium lighting
for our environmental
clownfish aquaculture project.
So this should be
classified as lab equipment.
And let's see if our model
is able to identify it.
So there we go.
We can see our model identified
this as lab equipment with 98%
competence, which is
pretty cool considering
it's not totally obvious
from the text itself
that this is the category
that should be assigned.
So again, similar
to AutoML Vision,
we get a custom
REST API that we can
use to make predictions on our
trained natural language model.
So we can go back to the slides.
We go back to the slides.
There we go.
So next, I'm moving right
along to AutoML Translate.
Before I dive into
AutoML Translate,
I want to talk about why
domain-specific translation is
important.
Because oftentimes, using
our Cloud Translation API
works great for many use cases.
But there are certain
situations where
you do need domain-specific
translation.
Maybe you have a lot of
industry-specific jargon
that you need to translate.
So I'm going to use this
error message as an example.
So the message says,
device driver software
was not successfully installed.
So let's say I wanted
to summarize this,
focusing here on
the word "driver."
Let's say I summarize this to
say, the driver is not working
and now I want to
translate that.
So taken out of context
of the error message,
this actually might apply
to a number of things.
So the sentence is the
driver is not working.
It could be referring
to a broken golf club.
My driver club is broken.
It could also be
referring to maybe a taxi
driver is on strike.
They're not working.
The driver is not working.
Or it could apply to
the software use case
that we saw on
the previous side.
So this is an example
of why you might
need a domain-specific
translation model.
To show you a demo, I'm going
to use a data set provided
by one of our customers.
Their name is
welocalize. welocalize
is one of the
largest localization
providers in the US.
And they help their
customers, which
span many different industries,
localize their content
for global audiences.
And so we're going to
highlight data sets provided
by two of their customers
that they have experimented
with AutoML Translate for us.
So those are OpenTable
and Blackboard.
So welocalize has a lot
of localization expertise,
because when you build an
AutoML Translate model,
you need to provide
it with thousands
of sentence pairs
translating from a source
to a target language.
So they have a team
of experts that
helps gather that training
data and analyze the quality
of the resulting model.
So what OpenTable did, they've
been experimenting with AutoML
Translate during the alpha.
They built a model that
translates from English
to German to
translate restaurant
reviews, descriptions, and
UI elements on the site.
For those of you that aren't
familiar with Blackboard,
it's an e-learning platform.
It helps teachers post
homework in their courses.
It lets students
engage in discussion,
and look up their
grades, things like that.
So they built a model to
translate from English
to Spanish to
translate user guides
and you UI elements
on their site.
So I noticed both
of these examples
translate from English into
a non-English language.
To show you a demo, I've
actually reversed the sentence
pairs so that they
translate into English
so that you can see
the benefits you get
from using the custom model.
The accuracy of the
reverse sentence pairs
is going to be pretty similar
to the original models
that they built.
So if we could go to the demo.
I'm going to show you a demo
for both OpenTable Blackboard.
They have different
data sets, obviously.
So this is what
the training data
looks like in AutoML Translate.
So here we have the
German-to-English sentence
pairs.
This is the OpenTable example.
So they're translating UI
elements, restaurant reviews,
and descriptions on their site.
So we go over here
to the Train tab.
You'll see what's
called a blue score.
And this is a score that's used
by neural machine translation
experts to evaluate the
accuracy of a train model.
So what you want
to see here is you
want to see a higher blue
score than the base model.
This is what the Translation API
would provide on the same data.
So here we got a
20-point improvement.
And what we want to do here
is generate a prediction
on some new text.
So I'm going to enter a
restaurant review in German.
And what we'll see up here is
what we get from our custom
model, and then we
can compare that
to what we get-- this is
the same exact response we'd
get if we used Google Translate
on this same sentence.
So let's take a look.
So the first sentence, "Service
was nice and friendly,"
this is actually the same.
So you don't always need a
custom translation model,
but there are certain
use cases where
it leads to a lot of
improvements in accuracy.
So here we see
this was translated
to "drinks were upscale," which
is a much better translation
than the word "lifted."
And then right here it says.
"We highly recommend,"
which, again,
is a better translation than
"we can only recommend."
So we get these
small improvements,
which do lead to a lot
of accuracy improvements
in the end.
So that's the OpenTable example.
Looking at a different
domain, let's take
a look at the Blackboard model.
So here I'm going to enter
some text in Spanish,
and we'll translate it, and
we'll compare the results here.
So here, we notice
right off the bat,
we get a better translation
here of this word.
So "graders" is
obviously a term that's
used across Blackboard's
application.
The baseline model
would translate this
to "qualifiers," which doesn't
really make sense in this case.
"Retention Center"
is a proper noun
in their platform, which is
translated more accurately
by the custom model.
And over here we
have "swiping" versus
"scrolling," "submission"
versus "shipments."
So "submission"
is what they want
to call submitting
something in their platform.
And then finally,
"submission listing,"
which is a better translation
than "ship list page."
So you can see for any
domain-specific translation use
case, you do get a lot
of quality improvements
by building a custom model
using your own training
data for that.
So we can go back to the slides.
And then moving into the
last part of the talk,
what if you have
a custom task that
requires more control over
your model type and its inputs?
So some examples of this
are, let's say you've already
built your own model.
You built a model in
TensorFlow or scikit-learn
and you want to
train that model.
So maybe you want to train
it on Google Cloud Platform.
Or maybe you want
to scale the way
to serve that model to handle
lots and lots of prediction
requests.
Another example is,
let's say you want
to build a regression model.
So that's a model that will
output numerical values.
So maybe you have a
text input and you
want your model to assign some
sort of rating to that text.
Or maybe you have a model
that has multiple inputs.
So maybe it takes images
and text as input,
and then outputs some sort
of prediction based on that.
So these are all use cases
where you want more control
over your model.
And for that we have Cloud
Machine Learning Engine, which
is Google's managed platform
for building, training,
and serving custom models
using your own data.
So it's our fully managed
platform for machine learning.
It supports a couple of
different frameworks.
So it supports TensorFlow,
Keras, and then most recently,
scikit-learn an XGBoost
models for serving.
So ML Engine is a way for
you to train your model.
So you can take advantage
of using GPUs or TPUs, which
stands for tensor
processing units, which
will help you accelerate your
machine learning workloads.
So you can use it for
training your models.
You can also use it for
serving your models.
So once you've got
a trained model,
you can serve it
on Cloud ML Engine,
and then you get access
to an easy-to-use API
to make predictions
on your trained model.
One of the great
things about ML Engine
is that there's no lock in.
So let's say that
I want to train
my model on my
own infrastructure
but then I want a
way to serve it.
I can upload it to ML Engine
for serving, or vise versa.
I could train it on
ML Engine and then
serve it somewhere else.
Some companies that are
using Machine Learning
Engine in production,
Rolls-Royce
has a TensorFlow model that
they're using for the company's
Marine Division.
And they have an
object detection model,
which means that it returns
the location of objects
in an image, similar
to the cat example
that I showed earlier
in the presentation.
They're using that
to identify and track
the objects that a vessel
can encounter at sea.
Another example is Ocado.
Ocado is the UK'S largest
grocery delivery service.
As you can imagine,
they get tons,
and tons of customer support
emails on a daily basis.
So they built a custom
model to optimize
how they handle those requests.
So some requests don't
require any response at all.
Some requests are very urgent.
So they're able to route
requests appropriately using
that custom model.
And to show you a
demo of ML Engine,
I'm going to bring
up my teammate,
Zach Akil to the stage.
Welcome, Zach.
[APPLAUSE]
ZACH AKIL: Thank you, Sara.
If we could switch
back to the slides.
Have we got--
Awesome.
So I'm Zach Akil.
I'm one of the developer
advocates for Google Cloud
Platform.
And I'm really
excited to show of how
we can use ML Engine to deploy
a custom model that we've built,
and then how we can
also integrate that
into an actual app.
So let's just jump right
in and look at the problem
that our app is going to solve.
So this fun.
On given a movie description,
can we predict the genre?
So this is an example of a
natural language problem.
But as Sara was saying,
we could have easily done
an image-based problem or
a numeric-based problem.
We've just chosen this one
because it's a bit of fun.
But it will be a bit special,
so let's look at an example.
So here's the description.
I believe it's one
of the Ocean's films.
It's got crime in it.
It's got action.
So for our model, instead of
predicting just a single genre,
we're actually going
to build it so that it
predicts multiple genres.
So this is an example of a
multi-label classification
problem.
And ML Engine will handle
this, like I said before,
because it doesn't really
mind what kind of problem
we're trying to solve.
It will just take the
models that we built.
So we've actually went to when
we've built a couple of models
to solve this problem.
And if you want to
have a go at solving
that kind of
movie-related problem,
we've actually used this
data set from Kaggle.
It's a really, really good one.
It's got like over
40,000 movies,
and we were picking genres.
And they're got loads
of other features
that we didn't even use.
So I really recommend
using that data set.
For the actual app
structure that we built,
we aimed to build an app
that's as simple as possible,
but one that's also
completely scalable.
So we built a front end
that's just static HTML.
You'll see it in a little bit.
It's a really simple
text box with a button
that you just click.
And we've actually just thrown
that up onto the Cloud Storage.
So Cloud Storage has
a really cool feature
where you can just throw up
an HTML file, click a button
to make a public link, and it'll
create a public URL that anyone
can just go to, and it will
render it as a web page.
So we've just used that
to host our front end.
And obviously, the back end is
going to be Cloud ML Engine.
That's going to do the heavy
lifting of actually hosting
our deployed models.
And more specifically, the
models that we've built
have been a combination of
scikit-learn and TensorFlow.
So you're probably already a
bit familiar with TensorFlow.
It's Google's deep
learning framework.
But is anyone in the room
familiar with scikit-learn?
Got any scikit-learn--
OK, got like a handful.
So scikit-learn is actually a
really comprehensive machine
learning library, but
it kind of specializes
in the parts of machine learning
that aren't deep learning.
So it has a lot of algorithms
for clustering, for decision
trees, and we're just
going to show you
how you can combine
a couple of models,
and why that can be advantageous
when you're trying to build
machine-learning algorithms.
So we've got our back end,
and we've got our front end.
How will we get predictions from
our front end to our back end?
We can send requests directly
from a JavaScript front end
to ML Engine.
The one restriction in
that is that all requests
have to be authenticated.
So we would have to build into
our front end a way for a user
to log in with their
Google credentials
and approve them
to our own model.
So that is actually a
really good solution
if you want to restrict
the users of your model
to be specific, so from
a certain user group.
But for our one, we want it
to be as simple as possible.
So we want users to be able
just go in, and without having
to log in, get predictions.
So that's where we
have a Cloud Function.
So we've built a really
simple Cloud Function.
All it does is it takes
whatever prediction
we're going to make--
so it's going to take the
description of the movie,
and it's going to just
slap on project credentials
and send it off to
Cloud ML Engine.
So it's not changing any data.
And a way you can
think about this
is it's providing an
authentication sugar glazing
on a prediction-request donut.
So it's not actually
changing any data.
It's just taking
the requests we're
going to make, putting
it on credentials.
And Cloud Functions actually
come with default credentials
for your project.
So they're really useful for
doing this sort of thing.
So let's actually stop talking
about it and just show it.
So we can switch
over to the demo.
So here is the Cloud
ML Engine dashboard.
So we can see our model
here and we can actually
look at our app, which is here.
So as I said, it was
a very simple app.
So it's just got a movie
description and a button.
So let's throw in a
movie description here.
So we've got this one.
This is one of the
Star Wars films.
Does anyone have any
predictions for what
genre it's going to be?
Just shout them out.
AUDIENCE: Sci-fi.
OK, we've got sci-fi.
We've got action.
OK, let's see.
So it's going to send a request
off to our Cloud Function.
That's going to go
off to ML Engine
and it's going to come
back with the genres.
So you can see here it's
predicted action, science
fiction, thriller-- is
Star Wars a thriller?
Maybe.
I don't know.
So we're making predictions.
That's the front end.
Let's look back at the back end.
So we can go back
to Cloud ML Engine.
So you can see
we've got our model.
It shows the default version.
So keep note of that because
we'll come back to that later.
So default version
is version one.
We can look at our model
and see that we actually
have two versions of our model.
We have version one
and version two.
So when I-- talking about how we
built a model with scikit-learn
and a model of
TensorFlow, version one
is our scikit-learn
model, and version two
is our TensorFlow model.
So we can go back to our app,
and we can get a prediction
from our TensorFlow model.
So I've just built in a
little UI here, and boom.
So that's getting predictions
from a scikit-learn model
alongside getting predictions
from a TensorFlow model.
And you can see here
we've got some numbers.
So the TensorFlow model,
rather than it returning
just the flags of
which genre it is,
it actually also
returns probabilities.
So we've just displayed
those as well.
And when we're making requests,
although I've showed it with
here with some radio buttons,
all I would do is I would
specify the model
name-- so in this case,
we have a model named movies--
and get prediction.
And that's going to go
off to our default model.
So that's where the
scikit-learn model.
So that's why we've got the same
tags as our scikit-learn model
because version one
was our default model.
So if we wanted to
be more specific,
we could say get from versions--
V1-- and that's also going to
go from our scikit-learn model--
and then version two is
our TensorFlow model.
So it goes to show
you how easy it
is to just switch between
versions of a model
when you're making predictions
on the application side.
So that's version one,
that's version two,
let's look at version three.
And whoops, we don't
have version three.
So let's actually go
create version three.
So over in our dashboard here,
we can go into the Cloud Shell.
It's going to boot up a
little mini instance for us
to interact with the Cloud.
And when it's up, we'll be
able to use the Google Cloud
API to build all our models.
So here's the dashboard.
Here's the instance shell.
We can use G cloud, and
it's just ML Engine.
And for example, we can just
list the models that we have.
Hopefully I've
spelled everything.
And it should show one
model called movies.
Make sense?
Now let's create a new
version of that model.
So if we go over to
our Cloud Storage--
I've actually created a really
simple decision-tree model
in sk-learn, and it's
just sitting here
in our cloud storage.
So I'll run the command.
I've cheated a bit here,
so I've copied and pasted.
I've made it before, but I'll
talk through what it does.
So we'll run it.
And what we're doing,
we're calling ML Engine.
We're saying, OK, you're
going to create a new version.
We're going to call
our version tree.
So our previous
versions were called
version one, version two.
We could have called
it version three,
but might as well mess with
the application engineers that
are going to build this
and make inconsistent
naming conventions.
So we'll call it tree.
We said, OK, it's going
to be a new version
for our model called movies.
The framework's going
to be scikit-learn.
Make sense?
The runtime version is 1.5.
And that is the runtime
version of ML Engine
that we're going to use.
And the reason why
we've chosen 1.5
is because that's the one
that supports Python 3
models that we've built. So
our scikit-learn model, when
we were building it, we were
building it using Python.
And it was in a
version of Python 3.
And so we tell it, OK,
use runtime version 1.5
because that supports
version three.
And then we've
specified, use Python 3.
And then we've just told it
where the model is actually
stored.
We stored it in that bucket
that I showed you before.
In fact, you can see it here.
And it's uploading now.
So what's really
exciting about why
you can upload a model
with just one command,
it goes back to the
sort of best practice
with machine learning
at the moment.
And that is this kind of
iterative, leap-frogging idea
when you're building models.
So the idea is that you build
a really, really simple model
to begin with, even if
it's underperforming.
And then stop, put
that to the side,
and then build a second model
to try to beat that model.
And you sort of leapfrog
with your models.
So this is great.
This is a great idea.
Except before you just build a
model and put off to the side,
but now, because deploying
is just one command,
you're able to build the
model and deploy the model.
And what's really
is cool about this
is that for
application developers,
they can immediately
start building
the application with
the first model,
and then whenever you upload
more complicated, more advanced
models, they don't need
to change the application.
So this is actually exactly
how we built this demo.
So I am more comfortable
with scikit-learn,
so I started building
a scikit-learn model.
And then I threw it
up on the ML Engine.
And while I was doing
that, Sara was actually
building a TensorFlow model.
And so when I threw it up on ML
Engine, my scikit-learn model,
I went off and I built the
front end that you saw.
And after the
front end was done,
and Sara had finished
the TensorFlow model,
she just threw it
up on the ML Engine
and I didn't need to
change my front end at all.
I was able to immediately
just get predictions from it.
I didn't need to worry about
installing dependencies.
And if you've tried to embed
machine-learning algorithms
directly into applications,
you know how much of a pain
this can be.
So that's what's really
exciting about ML Engine.
OK, so our model is uploaded.
We'll go back to our app.
We can see-- OK, we're
still getting predictions
from version one.
Sending off to Cloud ML Engine,
and it's going to come back.
Cool.
Version two, awesome.
Let's go back here.
Let's try version three.
It's going to fail because we
didn't call it version three.
We called it version tree.
And then you can see, it's a
really simple decision tree,
so it doesn't perform
quite as well.
But just to wrap up with this,
let's create our own movie.
So I'll say-- let's say the
tale of a rogue engineer trying
to deploy their model.
Any guesses for the genre?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
OK, there's a few.
Let's see scikit-learn model.
See what that gets.
Comedy.
[LAUGHTER]
I guess it's a funny one.
Let's see TensorFlow.
Action, science fiction,
that's pretty good.
OK, let's try to influence this.
So imagine we're a
production company.
We actually want
to make a romance.
So how would we call it?
We would say, all
that blah, blah,
blah, blah, who falls in love.
Who falls in love.
Let's see if any of our
models pick up on it.
OK, that one doesn't.
Scikit-learn, hey, we
now have a romance.
OK.
So we can switch
back to the slides.
I hope that's shown
you some of the power
that ML Engine can bring when
you're developing your custom
machine learning models.
And especially how it can
sort of bring together
your data scientists,
machine engineers,
with your application
engineers in a nice harmony.
With that, I will hand
you back over to Sara,
and enjoy the rest
of the conference.
[APPLAUSE]
SARA ROBINSON: Thanks, Zach.
It was an awesome demo.
Back to the slides.
So we covered a ton of
things in this presentation.
So I just wanted to give you
a quick summary to wrap up.
So if you remember
only three things
from the presentation,
1, use a pre-trained API
to accomplish common
machine learning tasks
like image analysis,
natural language
processing, or translation.
You don't need any of your
own training data to do that.
You can get started right away.
Just one REST API request.
Number 2, if you want
to customize these APIs
to your own specific
training data,
you can use Auto ML, currently
available for images, text,
and translation.
And then finally, as Zach just
showed us, for custom tasks,
you can build a model,
train it on your own data,
and train and serve it on
Cloud Machine Learning Engine.
So that's all we've got.
Here are some resources
if you want to learn more.
I'll let folks take a photo
of that side for a moment.
And thank you.
Thanks, everyone, for coming.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]